the Senate Intelligence Committee is one
of four congressional panels
investigating Russian interference in
the election the Senate Judiciary House
Oversight and House intelligence
committees are also holding hearings on
the issue congressman Adam shift is the
ranking member of the House Intelligence
Committee he joins us now from the
Capitol congressman good morning good
morning Charlie why do you believe that
there is in the opening statement by
James Comey an indication of obstruction
of justice when the president and
Republicans are saying including the
chair of the Intelligence Committee of
saying they don't see anything like that
well there's certainly evidence here and
if you were prosecuting a case of
obstruction you would admit the entirety
of Jim Comey's testimony and is not a
judge in the land that would exclude it
is not relevant to the question of
obstruction but the fact that there is
some evidence here doesn't mean that you
have proof beyond a reasonable doubt
this is obviously still very early
indeed we haven't even heard the oral
testimony of Jim Comey what I would look
to try to find out in today's testimony
among other things because I think we
have seen a lot of the outline of what
he has to say is who would be able to
corroborate this testimony who did he
share this information with what can you
tell us about the notes that he took and
when he took them what else can he tell
us about some of the details around
these conversations but if you have
evidence as we do now that the president
demanded loyalty from the FBI director
in a conversation where he dangles the
director's job before him then asked him
to drop a part of the investigation then
asked him to lift the Russia cloud and
then fires him when the director doesn't
do any of this to say that doesn't
constitute some evidence of obstruction
I think you have to be willfully looking
in the other direction well in terms of
corroborating it I mean he says in his
statement that he shared his
recollection and his memos with senior
FBI leadership at the time but let me
ask you this do you see intent on behalf
of the president in terms of obstruction
of justice well you know this is one of
the key issues and that is you have Jim
Comey's perception of what this might
mean you have the actual statements
themselves we're going to want I think
that as much detail as Jim Comey can
provide about those conversations were
there any
other statements that would shed light
on the president's intention and and in
this respect this is why we also cannot
accept I won't answer the question from
witnesses like director Coates and
director Rogers because if the president
had similar conversations with other
intelligence agencies agency heads that
is further indication of what the
president's intent is probably the
single best piece of evidence though I
would say of what we've seen in the
written testimony is the fact that the
president sent everybody else out of the
room why do that unless you're conscious
that what you're about to ask is not an
appropriate request it seems media
you're looking for what he did not say
in the opening statement rather than
what he said that you need something
else to make the case for production of
justice well I know I wouldn't put it
that way but I would say we know I think
from the four corners of his statement
largely what his testimony is going to
be I assume he's going to testify
completely consistent with that and I
would have to strongly disagree with my
colleague Lindsey Graham the fact that
Bob Muller is not worried about his
testifying I think doesn't suggest
anything about how Bob Muller views the
case indeed I would be astonished if he
had a view this early in the
investigation rather I think it shows
confidence that Jim Comey will be
consistent in his testimony before the
Senate and in any later proceeding but I
wouldn't read any conclusion into that
one way or the other congressman Schiff
thank you so much